welcome to this video playback see from
Finland let's see let's see Peck see
okay check I've played him just once
with a win do we get just the NIMS Oh or
something else d 6 cm okay let's just
take the center check I could have
played a day Queen a for winning a piece
right he does not have a knight on f6 I
could have just won a piece great great
okay okay anyway we get a position that
is at least I'm still comfortable for
white with a good good play in the
center I could have taken a small but ok
this this should be okay fine position
okay is he trying to play c5 sometime
maybe but ok let's play the normal moves
first and then think about concrete
measures hmm yeah how do we how do I get
near the King here
a move like g4s probably totally insane
right now maybe this this looks fine
anyway going probably 2h for the right
moment Queen g3 or complete development
first maybe I can get the Queen to h h
three and then G form at some point
like to have some noms probably his
defensive idea okay I wanted to provoke
this move so that now I have h4 h5
I still think you should think about c5
at some point playing in the center for
change here we go ok now h6 is not
really doing much how do i play this i
can try to play d5 yes i can try to
answer c5 with d 585 e6 so c5 LD 50 k
and d 5 is an idea anyway because of
this unlucky piece placement with Queen
9709 on f7 Saudi 5 is a serious move ok
d5 maybe also with Knight d4 being a
threat interesting them are difficult
position what should like do I stopping
this mechanical 85 maybe yeah maybe
right okay with the diagonal now closed
I can really with some justification at
least think about G form which was
totally insane before ok now it's not so
insane ok let's do it threatening to
take and get an e6 at the end so this is
this a serious
okay Queen takes on is that something
else much five or something no like I
need to take yeah okay so on d5 he wants
to take with the night I think mm-hmm
yes but isn't this isn't this really
dangerous the whole thing d5 Knight
takes Queen e4 how does he protect h7
interesting
that looks very dangerous he takes D is
not possible at all because these seven
hangs and 95 yeah even 95 cd5 Bishop d3
d6 is strong winning a piece but 95
greedy for is probably the the worst of
all yeah he has not seen the threat i
believe i guess the camp like when you
fall and wen hua ji 6 it looks totally
ad-lib utt yeah it's a good move in any
case let's do it
Knight takes I can I g5 getting Oh
Oh interesting I didn't think about that
at all okay maybe a rook h1 I don't
really have enough time to calculate the
whole thing rook h1 must come look h1 or
something else the capture here so
steeply irritating now time morning yeah
come on I don't have any time
if it takes do I have something better
than recapturing takes takes Queen takes
Queen takes is 6am it's very dangerous
but is it winning I don't know
counter-attack
very tough very tough position with no
time I cannot take twice because in this
really made on edge seven check check
it's a counter check it's a counter
check it's a check no oh no oh well
losing this is heartbreaking after all
that I cannot believe it oh my god my
little shy completely winning of course
check check check okay it's a check on
f6 oh no from this position unbelievable
oh my
I just didn't see it's a check with the
King on f2 sure Greenidge who I can only
resign no nothing else Jack Greene age
seven mate oh yeah this was actually a
very nice game I thought until I
blundered it away total one-way street
Jim there are Queen age for also winces
or wins it was very nice game really
what can i say i'm pretty pretty
satisfied with the way i totally
outplayed him but I didn't see it was a
check it sets all the best moves in
computer a greaser agrees fully maybe
Bishop g5 is this is quicker or anything
no it's not better yeah this is winning
what what can you do I just need to play
Queen edge for him maybe this wins as
well no we can take d3 here okay yeah
but this is not not so difficult really
i mean threatening the maid and he has
his absolutely no defense here check
check check
no assistance ah ok that's just forget
about it and start a new one thanks for
watching